oh no says could you say hello world for
us hello world fantastic
did the dominant linguistic theories of
the time consciously or unconsciously
Influenster design of certain
programming languages I suspect the
answer is yes in some ways I'm not sure
that I'm enough of a historian to know
for sure but for example languages like
C derived from languages like in
particular BCPL which of course were
influenced sometimes positively
sometimes in a sort of reaction and way
to alcohol which was really really
fundamental but also Fortran which was I
would say less theoretical in every
respect but very much more pragmatic in
a way so things are influenced by what
went before
and sometimes it's Wow we need more of
that and sometimes it's a we need less
of that and do something different so so
those would be examples C++ would be
another one influenced by the wonderful
engineering that went into C efficiency
obvious mechanisms and so on but at the
same time taking what came from Simula
the idea of classes in particular Samuel
is a language that I think didn't get
the recognition that it did when Tiger
got the Turing award for that was
recognition finally but C++ clearly
influenced by those two streams coming
together more modern example go which
the pragmatic part of it syntax than the
minimalism and so on very strongly
influenced by C but on the other side
the module structure influenced by all
of the things that came from alcohol
through class Fiat modular Pascal
modular Oberon all of those things and
then the communicating sequential
processes work of Tony Hoare so those
three streams come together and
certainly Tony horse view of this was
let's call it a theoretical approach so
all of these things come together so
it's not like things come full blown
from the head of Zeus they are based on
what has gone before I've got a few
people saying just pass on thank you
so thank you thank you all
what are your thoughts on writing
secured by design software and see today
is it better as a result for an
experienced programmers to use something
higher level something else I think
writing secure software you should do it
by design if you don't glue it on
afterwards that won't work you have to
think very carefully about what you do I
think the problem with C is that the
language itself doesn't provide you with
many mechanisms for making sure that
your code is secure so there's lots of
ways in which you can inadvertently make
a mistake in the compiler is not able to
help you and so for many purposes a
higher-level language would probably be
wiser because some of them may offer a
flaw is an obvious example that's a
buffer overrun is one of the common
things that goes wrong with C programs
it doesn't go wrong at least in that
sense with any language which is
manipulating strings or arrays for you
in keeping track of the bounds of them
so it's possible to screw up in any
language absolutely but I think C is by
design a very very sharp tool and you
can cut yourself as well as cutting
through things types of spaces tabs or
spaces I started out with tabs because
that's the way that UNIX was done ken
Thompson and Dennis Ritchie use tabs
everybody use tabs there was no notion
of spaces and this was partly the
minimalism and why type 4 characters
when you could type one but the problem
is that things tend to get wide after a
while and and especially the language
like Java which is intrinsically wide
I think spaces are a better fit for most
people and so I think now when I'm
writing my own code I mostly use spaces
and every once and all I get bitten
because there's a tab when there should
have been a space or vice versa some
languages in particular go enforce a
standard format period and the standard
format uses tabs and that's it
and but you can display the tabs as any
number of spaces so that the visual
effect is right
sinful would like to know what you're
involved in now innovations or
recreational comps are
I'm glad you qualify dick because
recreational my wife and I are on
vacation in England and having a
wonderful time
thank you technically at the moment I am
trying to gear up for class in the fall
where I'm going back after several year
layoff to the classes I've been teaching
for non-technical people uh and I did
that for a long time probably fifteen
years or more I can put in a plug for
the book called understanding the
digital world please buy many copies for
yourself and your friends but I had a
three year layoff on that and so I'm
back to doing that in the fall and of
course the world changes and so there
are things that I didn't cover properly
I think or enough in previous go arounds
that I want to include this time the
obvious things are things related to
machine learning big data and natural
language processing and so on what is
all of that stuff how do you explain
that for people who are not technical
but are probably going to be making
decisions on behalf of those who are
technical and so on that's one of the
things that I'm worrying about at the
moment the other thing that I've been
playing with often on in really as a
dilatant is issues in and around the
digital humanities we had talked earlier
about how computing spreads into lots
and lots of different areas so digital
humanities is basically doing with
computer the kinds of things of
analyzing data and drawing inferences
from it and making it available to other
people and so on that you do with any
other kind of data but the data comes
from really really interesting sources
often somewhat elderly this goes back to
my interest in history and so I have
been over the last couple of years I had
run computer science seminars that is
seminars for computer science students
who are doing independent work in
digital humanities studying datasets
from all kinds of weird things and I'm
in addition supervising independent work
one semester and senior thesis work for
undergraduates on digital humanities and
so I keep going on that but very much as
a dilatant I could talk for a long time
about it but it would become obvious
that it didn't
what I was talking about so that would
be fine and so that's another aspect and
of course the same kinds of things about
machine learning and natural language
processing and so on show up very much
in digital humanity there's a wonderful
thing here in England
it's called Old Bailey online org and
it's basically some University
Consortium I guess digitized all of the
records of the Old Bailey from the late
1600s until the early 1900s
these had been court records right
transcriptions had been taken from as I
say the late 1600s right into the early
1900s and they were all digitized put
together in XML format and now you can
search them and find out things like
well there was probably some guy named
Sean Riley in the 1700s who was hanged
for stealing a pig or something like
that it's just absolutely a wonderful
amazing database it's at close to two
hundred thousand cases very carefully
documented with the names of perps and
the victims and the witnesses and the
judges and that what happened to the
people when they were convicted one
things I had not realized until I saw
this was you've heard of transportation
you know if you had been if you've done
something bad you were transported and
of course everybody thinks
transportation meant Australia no
transportation before 1776 men you were
shipped off to the United States which
wasn't the United States at that point
it was just the colonies and that might
explain all kinds of things so and then
you move it across the surface and what
you're picking up on is the interaction
item right at the end of the tip with
the atoms at the surface so you move
back and forth back and forth and build
up an image